i did not watch a single second of the
super bowl yesterday i don't care about
football i really don't care about
football ever since they totally caved
to blm and disrespected our country it's
not my thing
i used to enjoy gambling on the super
bowl at least being in a pool was kind
of fun but now
the nfl doesn't like our country i don't
like the nfl simple as that
i did however catch clips
of the advertisements and the halftime
show afterwards
and all that that they were selling the
most prominent
ads
and the halftime show obviously all it
was selling
was nostalgia
oh do you remember when you were a kid
oh do you remember when everything was
just about indulging your own desires
and delusions and fantasies kind of like
this kid working this kid he's a fully
grown adult working at the the biden
department of energy who pretends that
he is a a doggy or he pretends that his
sexual partners are doggies and it's
really creepy and weird and none of this
should be
encouraged publicly
but it's the same old it's just
indulging in childish
delusions and what the super was selling
was all nostalgia nostalgia
is history after a few drinks okay
nostalgia is
all the happy moments that we remember
or imagine and none of the tough moments
and other things we've overcome to
become the adults that we are today the
creepiest ad of the entire super bowl
came from facebook which has now renamed
itself meta because it's trying to
expand beyond
beyond just a regular old social network
where you can like people's photos and
catch up with old friends they want to
expand into a whole universe the
metaverse where you put on your gut you
sit in your apartment alone you put on
your goggles and you enter into
candyland where you can do whatever you
want you can fly around you're not
allowed to grope people anymore that was
a problem in the beta testing but
they've gotten rid of that so if you
want to do that you got to go to the
weird doggy dungeon with the department
of energy guy but when you're in the
metaverse you can just
relive
your past as though time has never moved
on
[Music]
so here you see
there's like little stuffed animals
playing old-timey songs
and then
i moved on
the diner is closed
the stuffed animal musicians go to a
pawn shop
grow up now they've got they've been
discarded
it's not fun anymore
a little long in the tooth please i was
just in a museum
this had so much more boring than their
fun youth
they were all playing those old songs
from the 80s
oh but now they're in the magical
metaverse world they put the goggles on
and no one has gotten any older
everyone's the same young age they were
in the 80s
and the diner well diner doesn't exist
anymore but in this imaginary world the
diner does exist
mediquest ii
go back and be a child
here's my
public service announcement for anybody
who is tempted to to indulge this kind
of stuff grow up grow up stop being a
child and be an adult and accept
responsibility and stop being so
freaking selfish and immature oh my gosh
people
people this is so true it's so it's
clearest on the weird sex stuff like the
weird guy playing around and pretending
he's a dog at the department of energy
but it's just it's true in our whole
culture
the fact that now
not 20 year old college students say
they need a safe space with crayons and
puppies it's the same it's the same
problem the fact that now you have
employees at major companies who say
they need space to cry
they need crying rooms
they do they they say this in at law
school georgetown law school the dean of
the law school said to what 25 26 30
year old students you need you need
space to cry if your feelings are hurt
this is the the same thing you're seeing
with people refusing to get married
among millennials and especially gen z
they're still slightly young for this
but you're starting to see some of the
data no one wants to get married and
with the millennials they're now old
even though they all pretend they're
still 17 years old but they're older and
they still won't get married i'm not
saying you have to get married marriage
isn't for everybody but they they're not
they're not consecrating themselves to
religious life they're not they're not
moving forward they're just remaining in
a perpetual adolescence that meta ad
it was fine it was a well-produced ad
but frankly i prefer the original
version of that ad
i won't grow up
[Music]
not me that's the that's the song of the
millennial generation
i'm a millennial but that's that's what
we all sing i won't grow up
even this phrase you know millennials
use this phrase adulting
the first time they pay taxes or
whatever they say i'm boy i'm adulting
yeah you're 40. i hope you're adulting
the people who who refuse to move out of
their parents home
not because even they have particularly
close relationships to their parents
just because they don't want to pay
bills they don't want to go move on
they say well i can save money yeah
because you're not paying your bills
because you're not acting like an adult
you should act
like this is my psa it's i'm not i don't
want to be overly harsh here i want to
harsh anyone's mellow but you need to
grow up because if you don't grow up
you're going to end up as a 35 year old
puppy fetishist okay you are you are
because
because if you think that it's okay
in your adulthood during a time when you
should be maturing and taking on
responsibilities and contributing to
your country and leaving your kids who
hopefully you're some some of us are
having kids i hope i hope some people in
this generation or the country is just
going to completely collapse
but hopefully you're leaving them a
better country
than you had hopefully you're you've got
to enjoy a nice little childhood now
you're going to give back
but if you are living under the
delusion that it's okay just to indulge
whatever fantasies
and whatever delusions and whatever
weird desires that you have then you're
going to end up dancing around in weird
costumes
pretending that you're six years old
except creepier because it involves sex
stuff when you're in your 30s or 40s
don't do that it's weird it's degraded
it's
embarrassing
don't you can't go back you can't go
back to never neverland okay don't go 40
years ago ronald reagan saw a massive
inflation unlike anything the country
had ever seen before
until today
in reagan's own words
inflation is as violent as a mugger as
frightening as an armed robber and as
deadly as a hitman
right now your retirement accounts are
under attack thanks to the inflationary
policies of this administration if you
have not yet called birch gold to the
only people that i would trust to help
you diversify your 401ks and iras into
gold then you are missing the boat
actually you're treading water without a
life vest birch gold has your life vest
let them help you convert an ira or 401k
into a tax sheltered ira in gold with
thousands of satisfied customers and an
a plus rating with the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings right now text
knowles know w l e s to 98 98 98
you will get a free info kit on gold
reagan knew the biggest threat to our
wealth protect yours now here's what you
do you pull out that phone you say
2989898 and you text the word knowles
k-w-l-e-s to get your free info kit now
i'm glad you like that clip now
please ring that bell subscribe
you can get the notifications here when
our new videos come out and if you don't
you can head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
podcast leave a five star review we will
see you next time
[Music]